nous fêtons ce soir l'un anniversaire en
famille et nous attendons notre invité
d'honneur monsieur le duc de jardin le
comte et la comtesse du vanneau de
chavignol et leurs chiens
le général de verdel montpied beloeil
mont vironneau mon général
parfait son aide de corps le colonel la
cac
le baron de loups blabla mental il ya de
l'emploi de sarria ne gagnent pas leur
aide ou sa fille georgette lebrun notre
invité d'honneur au pays se passe c'est
exaltant sabotage mais normes et écoute
que ça se fait dans toutes les familles
quand il ya un anniversaire jeudi non
mais ça se fait dans les familles mais
mais la télévision ça fait pas ce truc
là non envoyez-moi cent mille vols
allez monsieur gilbert bécaud